Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam với video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo
Nam Block sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách giãn
dòng và dán đoạn trong Word
a
đối với các phiên bản gốc khác nhau thi
thao tác gián đoạn hoặc giãn dòng trong
Word đều tương tự nhau và ngay bây giờ
Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc sẽ đi vào từng phần
chi tiết
phần duy nhất cách giãn dòng trong Word
trong video này Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc sẽ
chia sẻ với bạn 2 cách thực hiện cách
tốt nhất bạn thao tác chiến thành rất
buồn và cách thứ hai bạn sử dụng hộp
thoại paragraph trong Word
ra sửa thế giới này đâu bà Nam có lúc đã
chuẩn bị sẵn một đoạn văn bản thi cách
duy nhất để dán dòng trong Word và thực
hiện như sau
Bước 1 bạn Model phần văn bản cần Gian
Dòng ở đây giả sử mình sẽ Bôi đen phần
văn bản này
hay đoạn đầu tiên
sau đó Bước thứ hai à các bạn Click vào
icon dãn dòng đó là like and photographs
packing cái quần này sẽ nằm ở Tab home
bạn vào tác home sau đó click và enter
này và bạn chọn một cái khoảng cách phù
hợp Ví dụ như 1.15
1.015 hoặc 2.0 vân vân ví dụ giả sử ở
đây mình sẽ chọn khoảng cách là một trăm
năm
khi ban Thấy phần văn bản mình vừa mô
đen đã được giãn dòng rộng hơn so với
đoạn văn bản thế giới
như vậy Đỗ Bảo Nam blog vừa thực hiện
cách giãn dòng trong Word thứ nhất thông
qua tắc home và Click vào icon app right
and photographs spacing
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang Cách thứ hai
cách hai này là sử dụng hội thoại feta
grab hi các bước bạn thực hiện như sau ở
mức duy nhất anh vẫn Model phần văn bản
muốn dòng ở đây giả sử Đỗ vào Nam Block
đã bôi ăn sẵn từ lúc nãy
sao đâu bất hai bạn mở hội thoại fanta
grab để thiết lập khoảng cách giữa các
dòng
bạn có thể cưới chuột phải vào cái phần
văn bản mà bạn vừa qua đen
sau đó chọn feta grab
khi một hội thoại fanta crash hiện ra
bạn
tìm đến cái phần Speaking
và ở trong phần mic vệ sinh này bạn có
thể chọn một kiểu dãn dòng phù hợp Ví dụ
1.52 thì nó sẽ tương tự như khoảng cách
mà mình vừa dán dòng rồi giờ sửa đây
mình sẽ chọn đắp bồ chắc là sẽ bằng hai
và ok thì như vậy khoảng cách đã được
chỉnh xong ra so với lúc trước
bây giờ mình sẽ chỉnh lại cái khoảng
cách này cho nhỏ
Ờ thì đầu tiên bạn vẫn gỗ đen cái phần
văn bản cần dòng
sau đó bạn cứ chờ phải chọn festa grab
ở đây giả sử nhưng mình sẽ chọn là rất
ít
và bạn có thể nhập chính xác một cái
khoảng cách nào đó ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ
nhập là 14 - hạn
sau khi nhập xong bạn sẽ nhìn thấy cái
phần xem trước ở preview này và mình sẽ
có gì vợ Ok Như Vậy khoảng cách giữa các
dòng đã được thu nhỏ lại
và như vậy Vừa rồi đỗ vào Nam vào lúc
vừa chia sẻ hai cách dán dòng trong Word
tiếp theo độ Bảo Nam vào lúc sẽ sang
tuần thứ 2 cách dán đoạn trong Word
bây giờ giả sử mình vẫn thực hiện ở
Ký phần văn bản này và các bước để gián
đoạn trong mốt bạn thực hiện như sau A ở
bước thứ nhất bạn Bôi đen văn bản cần
giai đoạn ở đây mình sẽ mua đem ba cái
đoạn văn bản này
ạ sau đó có thể hai bạn mở cái hộp thoại
phantogram lúc nãy và chỉnh cái cái
trước gián đoạn
các bạn có thể kích vào cái ai cần mũi
tên trong cái bóp punjab của cái tóc hôm
này để mở hộp thoại paragraph I
Uh cho nó bạn tìm đến phần Face Dinh ở
đây before tức là khoảng cách ở phía
trước của đoạn ở đây giả sử mình sẽ tăng
lên
8pt
hoặc là 12V cũng được ví dụ ở đây mình
sẽ chọn là 12 PT vn Mình sẽ chọn làm 12
PT
sau khi bạn đã chỉnh cái khoảng cách ở
trong phần spacing ở mục before và after
thì bạn có thể xem trước được cái khoảng
cách giữa các đoạn trong cái bóp cho nó
kêu này và bây giờ mình sẽ Click vào ok
thì bạn ấy các bạn đã có một khoảng cách
rộng hơn so với ban đầu
và như vậy trong nội dung vừa lâu vừa
rồi Đỗ Bảo Nam blog vừa chia sẻ nhanh
với bạn cách giãn dòng và dán đoạn trong
Word
cho mấy bạn có những câu hỏi cần được hỗ
trợ bạn anh comment trực tiếp ở phía
dưới video này Cám ơn bạn đã theo dõi
video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các
video tiếp theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam với Đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video cũng từ đỗ vào Nam vlogs Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào năm đó
và truy cập website đâu Bảo Nam
blach.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nữa bà Năm blog để xem
thêm các video vui như thủ thuật máy
tính tay calypso Cruiser
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint em
và bạn có thể truy cập Website là đỗ bàn
ăn một lúc chúng con để cập nhật những
bài viết đối mới nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo